[Music]
i don't think it's true that political
outcomes in the west the brexit vote the
election of trump were in any
significant way influenced by
um bot farms by the manipulation of
social media that's a conspiracy theory
and the fact that the progressive left
believed
it's not conspiracy
let me let me let me finish
by various groups to achieve change it
may be wrong in their judgment but it's
not a conspiracy to say it is happening
okay
roger roger so i was i was prone to
believe this and i wrote something to
this effect reporting on this saying
this is really interesting work you
should read this an ex-google software
engineer who was tasked by google with
looking into in depth whether uh social
media like twitter like facebook were
being manipulated by bot farms either in
russia or china looked into it in great
depth said there's nothing to it toby
don't believe it it's a conspiracy
theory
analytica have no idea what they're
talking about cambridge analytica are
just a conspiracy theory guys toby young
has got the scoop for you today for
god's sake seriously
i think we all agree that we're in a
polarized moment that that there is a
high degree of intolerance and i just
want to ask whether you feel that this
is going to get worse or is it going to
get better if it's going to get better
how does it get better what do we do
miriam please start oh thank you um so
um i think it's got to get wor it's
going to get worse before it gets better
and i think we are slowly uh reaching
breaking point in my opinion i think
that there's a growing uh movement uh
even among uh the young people that um
toby would uh mischaracterize this
generation woke um who who really uh do
not identify with the polarization
that's currently happening that don't
necessarily uh agree with uh certain
views but definitely think that they
should be heard and um and find it quite
uncomfortable that there's a situation
now where there are uh views that are
being uh sort of marginalized to the
point where they're no longer being
allowed to express particularly on
debates that might be um quite new uh
quite um important to uh you know the
the future of our society and so i think
that their that voice is growing i see
it growing um and i think that that's
the voice that will eventually um take
the lead on this issue and and what that
lead is is essentially saying this look
um
disagreeing with someone is a really
important part of the democratic
principles that we most of us in this
society uh subscribe to and so we've got
to figure out mechanisms in order to
protect that having said that there are
obviously issues that are going to be
deeply uh emotive and maybe the question
is and i've said this before in my work
is that you know emotion is a fuel for
change but it isn't a framework and the
conversations we have to have are around
the frameworks for change so yes you're
allowed to feel anger you're allowed to
feel sadness you're allowed to feel
enraged but that can't be how you enter
a conversation just like in your
personal life when you're feeling super
annoyed super frazzled is not the best
time to go and speak to your partner
about the issue that you know you're
having a disagreement about right same
goes for society we're allowed to feel
those emotions but we need to find
spaces in which those emotions are
somewhat uh placated in order to allow
us to focus on the frameworks which can
allow for a conversation that allows us
to move forward and i think there is um
contrary to what is uh regularly uh
peddled on this issue a real recognition
that it is voices on the margin which uh
which makes society advance and and have
done historically and so we can't we
cannot drown those out um and now i i
just think that unfortunately a lot of
the conversation around this issue is
being pushed by people who actually deep
down what they're resentful of is
minorities finally being able to call
out the majority stakeholders in our
society and that's what they're deep
down a bit pissed off about they're like
oh how dare you come and um challenge us
this is our monopoly over power we we
hear that point thank you thank you can
i respond to can i respond to that
isabelle and respond to your question
too
just on the last point that miriam made
um the curious thing is it isn't for the
most part minorities um uh canceling
uh white heterosexual middle-aged men
it's younger heterosexual white people
who are often more privileged than the
people they cancel so if you look at the
outrage mob that formed on the new york
times and ended up getting jim bennett
fired for having the audacity to publish
an a piece on the comment pages by a
republican senator they weren't
minorities they were ivy league educated
extremely privileged white people and
often being woke is a form of social
signaling it's a way of signaling your
high status well more broadly i'd like
to agree with marion
miriam i think it's true uh that we need
to hear um uh uh
we need to hear from disadvantaged
groups we need to hear from marginalized
people and the best way to hear from
them is to stand up for free speech the
idea that there is a conflict between
pale male and stale that conservatives
like me and minorities when it comes to
defending free speech is a false binary
a false opposition it's in all of our
interests and the reason i say that is
if you look at the history of the civil
rights movement of the gay rights
movement even more recently of the trans
rights movement and all of them have
depended upon the hard-won uh battles
fought by organizations like the aclu in
the 1960s to defend freedom of speech
the way to become less polarized is if
we become more tolerant more patient
with those who we disagree with don't
try and cancel them which i'm afraid is
generation rock's go-to reaction let's
listen to each other let's stand up for
the right to free speech and bring
everybody into the conversation roger i
want to bring you into the conversation
you've talked about uh the need to
return to tolerance or the need to have
a tolerance of views and and not go to
ad hominem criticism how do we do that
in this in this polarized moment well i
think that
you see i'm really
i could if i'm being optimistic in this
terrible situation with kobet i would
say what kerpit has actually
demonstrated is
that none of us is special that we're
all together in this to a degree some
people can protect themselves with
wealth a bit more but not much and i've
noticed iran and maybe a much greater
sense of community paradoxically when
you can't meet so maybe the longer term
psychological impact of cobit and the
way in which you know it makes
nationalist ideas of national
independence
ludicrous in many areas
maybe we will see a greater forms of
cooperation and greater sense of society
but i think two things one is it
requires requires three things i would
say first of all it requires
universities and others to be much more
robust i agree with toby on this and you
must
not have no we mustn't have no
platforming
we must have the widest range of voices
at the same time it's crystal clear that
most of us are and certainly people like
me are poorly informed about the reality
of black lives and what happens are
poorly and
poorly
informed about colonialism and there
needs to be a course correction in
teaching of history and other things to
understand these issues
and i do think the third thing is that
organizations like the bbc which has
flaws
must be ultimately protected as a place
where you can have investigation before
you have outrage i mean when toby's
going on about certain statistics about
black one this happened to be a matter
of debate it taught to be something that
can be
discovered because it's a fact and when
discovered we should then look at
possible wider explanations for the
event but we should be arguing backwards
and forwards that if he says it can't be
true because he's white what they say
must be true because they're black
surely there's still a vast role for
sensible straightforward journalism to
establish the facts about
and then we then we disagree about
causes then we disagree about solutions
but we don't spend our time disputing
facts
but isn't that one of the
characteristics of this for of this kind
of polarization the alternative facts
argument after all we don't disagree we
don't agree on the fact
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas